Heyyy, how's it going?
*mic*
It's time to watch some Pewdiepie memes.
You bros- You bros submitted them.
250 pages!
Jesus
Ainsley!
[whispering] It's free real estate
"When you're not a vegan but she thinks you need a powerful core message."
[High pitched ding]
*laughs* What....
These are not funny *laughs*
Why am I laughing?
"That face when you lost six-"
6--
Actually I didn't even care that much.
They were all inactive subscribers, I'm- I'm happy for them to be gone...
*Sad music plays* "They ask you how you are, and you just have to say that you're fine and you're not really  fine."
"That feeling when Sorsha makes yoga pants illegal"
Wait, wait, yoga pants are illegal?
*incoherent shouting*
"The development of the butterfly"
*Music plays
*laughs*
*giggle*
Yeah, that's pretty accurate man
*Music plays*
OOOOOHHHHHHH!!
[Distorted Echo] WHY WOULD YOU DO THAT?
"When you see someone telling [Laughing] Marzia"
[Laughing]
Oh man
Those fucking underpants.
What the shit is that?
When you're pissed of but he says something fun- [Laughing]
Can we not make crying Poods a thing? Please?
Thank you VERY much!
"Yes mum he makes money off this shit"
Yeah my mom still doesn't believe it either it's okay...
"Dat moment when you see yo momma naked"
*laughs*
"When you gotta get down on her but she's hairy as fuck"
I am....
So immature
"When the Swedish meatball has a good spiceness"
[Laughing]
That's so bad...
[Laughing] It's so bad!
"Rare photo of soldier about to storm the beaches of Normandy"
Oh man
I don't know if I'm tired, or why, but this is really funny! [laughs]
"Hey you surf YouTube too?"
"Yeah I love malcom 1466"
[Laughing]
Hey, Malcolm is on our side now guys
Malcolm is one of US!
That's - it's good.
[Laughing]
Fuck you
"Hey it's-a the PewDiePie Bros!"
"Mama, why you-a never remember my name?"
"I'm-a sorry green PewDiePie"
[Laughs weirdly]
[Laughing]
Ohhh [laughs]
"Attempting a sexy cosplay"
"Expectation"
[Laughing]
*laughing*
Nice, I see what you did there
*music plays* That's- cle- you- you thin- you think that- I bet you think that you're clever
"When both your girlfriends...ha- has-have better beards than you"
[Snorts]
[Laughing] Fuck you
"Has 47 million subs, 4 million people watch him"
OH YEAH?! You think that's funny?
[High pitched ding]
[High pitched mocking voice] Why does PoodiPie only have 4 million views per video?
OH? ONLY 4 million!!
[Distorted voice] ONLY !?!
[Sad piano music plays in background] What have I done to deserve such a sweet fanbase?
That is just so nice to me and j-just shows s-so much love, and always likes my videos.
Always writing positive comments
Always has a positive core message
You bros are just, the best!
Yeah
"One does not simply make YouTube [laughs] without a core message"
That's a good meme...that's a good- I can appreciate that meme.
[Laughing]
"When Pewds start the outro, but keeps talking you be there like..."
Ha ha ha ha
*croaking* Ughhhhh, that's funny, that's real funny!
Ah ha heh
Now for fu-f- what, w-we don't look alike at alll!
Oh my god...
Fuck's sake
OH my GOD [laughs] God damn it!
[Laughing]
Ughh
That's my screensaver now
That's my fucking screen saver right there
[Drumroll] "And the diamond playbutton goes to..."
"I mean, the winner actually is..."
[Laughing]
Oh, that's - I love the Jacksepticeye memes!
"Yeeeee"
[laughs]
Yeah
"Yeeee"
That was really fun
I really enjoyed that
I really enjoy that you bros take, ehhh, my videos or whatever and you make your own kind of humor.
I really enjoy that you bros have a great sense of humor
And, uh, I really enjoy the interaction between you and me
That's, uh, why I like reading the comments
I think it's, uhhhh fun that we're all part of a ngh-guh-g - universe!
The poodi-poo-the PoodiVerse
I really do, I think, uh, that's im-that's important
And  uhh, I appreciate you *Smooch*
*DISTORTION*
Thank you so much for all the submissions
We're gonna announce a new competition for two weeks from now
It's gonna be a PewDiePie remix!
We did one of this, probably five years ago
And it was FUCKIN' awesome!
You can remix whatever you want PewDiePie related.
I'm gonna add some samples that you can download as well, all the info is down in the description.
I just really appreciate you bros, doing this, I think it's so much fun. It makes me ehhhh, I feel like we're finally back.
I just really appreciate you bros doing this and it feels like we're finally back
And I fff-
It sounds forced
It's- it sounds forced, but I- I really feel like, I used to have such a great connection with your brss, back in the day
And then my channel got way too big and I just didn't know how to handle with it
And I think we these sort of stuff, I finally feel like we're-we're getting, we-I still have that again and, uh, I really appreciate that.
I think that's... uhhhhh
It means a lot to me.
*sad piano music*
BYE!